speak to James Bas our diplomatic editor
who will help us unpack all of that and
James I think all sides all the voices
that we've heard so far agree that this
is a step in the right direction yes
even the US ambassador Linda Thomas
Greenfield who did not vote for this
resolution but she abstained she said
that she supported many of the things in
uh the resolution um important I think
to remind you of the key provision of
this resolution the security Council now
calls this is binding international law
remember for the Urgent and extended
humanitarian pauses and corridors
throughout the Gaza Strip for a
sufficient number of days to enable
consistent with International
humanitarian law the full Rapid Safe and
unhindered humanitarian access for
United Nations humanitarian agencies and
their implementing Partners so they have
now said they have now voted for not
just a pause of a few hours but
something which would be a sufficient
number of days to allow the aid to
spread out all over the Gaza Strip uh
will Israel comply I think is question
the next question I mean how do you go
about enforcing that well it is binding
international law but we know there are
many Security Council resolutions that
are binding international law that
Israel does not comply with uh but I
think it will add added pressure on
Israel particularly as the US decided to
let this resolution go through it could
have used its veto and it's worth
telling you as you talked about those
previous resolutions that didn't go
through the previous four resolutions
probably the one that was the most
one the nearest to going through was the
one on the 18th of October that's when
all the countries either voted for or
abstained and the only country that
voted against was the United States it
wielded its V veto on October the 18th
well we've had 29 days since that date
and we know all the death toll figures
are probably un under counting but in
that time there have been
7,600 more deaths and
3,653 of those death deaths were
children so very sobering statistic and
and what was called for then was a
resolution calling for humanitarian
pauses what the US has now allowed 29
days later to go through the objection
at the time from the US ambassador who
put her hand up against and blocked that
resolution 29 days ago was that uh she
was unhappy that they hadn't explicitly
mentioned Israel's right of self-defense
and there was no condemnation of Hamas
well guess what
neither of those are in this resolution
either right let's talk in briefly if we
can about this attempt by Russia to
amend this resolution their key point
was that they wanted wording that
included the phrase sustainable truce
what were the objections there why did
that not land with the uh well that was
that was a call for a ceasefire and the
US had made it clear that a permanent
sear is something that it would block uh
and so I think the other countries that
voted against that voted against it
because it knew that that would be the
US veto coming through even if they
those countries did want to cease fire
uh they certainly didn't want to have
another veto they wanted to have
something that maybe the UN can work
with on the ground remember we've heard
earlier on today uh from the un's
emergency relief coordinator the under
Secretary General for humanitarian
Affairs Martin Griffith who has made it
absolutely clear that the UN the whole
un system is on its knees right now uh
there is no fuel
as we've seen the devastating effect
that's had on the hospitals uh we are
people close to starvation we have the
possibility with so many people crammed
into Gaza um of of serious disease
breaking out the UN believes that the
whole of Gaza City that part of it that
hasn't been completely destroyed is a
Breaking Point as is in the UN system
and the UN desperately needed this to
happen uh it is good news but will
Israel comply yeah silence the guns said
Martin griffi James B many thanks for
that would just